il était au parc jarry pour une marche
mais pas seulement j'ai aussi que les
aînés on est réveillé et qu'ils ont des
revendications parmi les voeux formulés
est la gratuité pour les transports oui
parce que c'est pas tous les aînés quand
une certaine aisance exaucé d'un côté
rendre le transport collectif gratuit
comme de l'eau la gratuité du transport
en commun pour les personnes de 65 ans
et plus mais les convergences entre
valérie planté denis coderre ne s'arrête
pas là sera pas de l'ain du surplus des
taxes foncières nos rapports d'impôt
foncier pour les personnes et me voilà
je trouve c'est important le père c'est
important de sortir de chez souhait
exaucé aussi profiter des installations
récréatives sont mises de l'avant
équipements sportifs adaptés aux aînés
dans les parcs il faudrait poké de
distance entre les générations et donc
mieux faire entendre la voix des aînés
l'équipe denis coderre mettra sur pied
une instance et rappelle que déjà en
2018 un sens montréal déposé une motion
pour créer un conseil des aînés que
l'administration plainte a
malheureusement choisi de ne pas adapter
mais aujourd'hui l'engagement c'est de
créer un conseil des doyennes et des
doyens de montréal
autre chose qui améliorerait la qualité
de vie des personnes plus âgées
serait-ce qu'au niveau de la sécurité
la circulation
elles font partie des piétons les plus
vulnérables 55% des piétons qui sont
décédés étaient âgés étaient âgés de 65
ans et plus un plan de sécurisation et
d'entretien des trottoirs et notamment
sur la table et il ya du travail exemple
ce trottoirs abîmés dans côte-des-neiges
suis déjà tombé à cause
une réparation de cette section par
l'arrondissement est prévue pour 2022 ou
2023 seulement
la ville centre pourtant vient de
refaire la rue juste devant c'est le
manque de considération pour les piétons
j'irai en fait c'est plutôt le manque
d'arrimage entre les deux niveaux de
décision car les piétons et en
particulier les aînés seront un
électorat très courtisé pour le 7
novembre ici mathieu prost radio canada
montréal